here we are with NASCAR right around the
corner Darlington and then Charlotte
seven races in 11 days and joining us
right now the driver of the number nine
NAPA Auto Parts Chevrolet Camaro for a
Hendrick Motorsports currently third and
the standings of the paused and NASCAR
season that has appears to be on the
verge of being unpause chase Elliott
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
chase all doing good appreciate fish
that y'all have me no appreciate you
being had walk me through your
preparations right now for Darlington
chase yeah it's really interesting
honestly we there's really not a lot we
can do you know with the with the rules
kind of eating the way they are and and
having limited practice and some stuff
nowadays anyway but yeah it'll be it'll
be interesting you know I mean NASCAR's
never you know never seen really
anything like what we're about to see
this year and you know showing up I'm
just racing without any on track time or
any prep you know inside the cars is
super unorthodox and has never you know
has never really even been considered
until until all this so part of me is
excited I think it's exciting to have
something new I'm excited that you know
we're gonna be back on TV and give our
fans you know something to watch you
know the part of me I hate that we're
even in the situation that that we're in
but I think the silver lining is that
you know we're gonna be able to offer
something to our viewers on TV and you
know at least we're you know we're back
racing and some some capacity no doubt
but Lily if you don't mind I'd love to
get in some more questions about how
this is going to work because you know
this could be a model potentially for
other sports that certainly so many
people are close in proximity to each
other and so is your crew the rest of
your crew and your team currently
quarantined right now to make sure that
everybody is kovat
negative being tested before Darlington
chase yeah I think that's currently all
being all being worked out right now
NASCAR was going to have a procedure of
some sort I don't really have any
details to share unfortunately been you
know that there's going to be some type
of some type of procedure that we all
have to go to or go through to basically
get approved I'm assuming you know it's
at the very least so I you know I look
forward to you know just getting to the
racetrack I look forward to learning
more about it you know I really don't
know
it's all very fluid I think things are
changing daily and you know I think the
bottom line is they you know as a as a
sanctioning body see an opportunity for
us to be able to go back racing in a in
a safe manner for for all of us and I
think if you know we can
procedurally cover all the you know all
the corners of everything that we need
to do to make sure everybody stays safe
I think we can do it and and do it
successfully so do you feel safe does it
feel safe to you or not just I'm not
just talking about covin you mentioned
how you're not going to spend any time
in the car before yeah before racing so
I mean do you feel safe over all this
chase I do I do you know I think that
they're going about it in a manner that
is as cautious you know cautious enough
that I feel I feel fine you know from
the from the racing side of the things I
you know think that from from my
standpoint you know we've we've run five
races this year yes it is going to be
odd to just hop back in the car but you
know the majority of the guys in the
field have you know already run those
five races so you do have a little time
I know it's been a couple months but I
think after you know after a period of
time in the race I think everybody will
be back in the in the form and then
certainly by you know that second third
race I think everybody will be be up to
speed chase Elliott right here on the
Rich Eisen show getting set for for
Darlington and then getting set for
Charlotte after that and
what are you being told about after all
that should everything go according to
plan and everybody has some safe races
and and nobody tests positive and I
guess you know what I mean like so what
are you being told about if you will
over the steering wheel Jason yeah
honestly that's that's so far above me I
don't even bother asking you know it's I
think I think you know plans and things
for Darlington are changing rapidly so
I'm not even sure how it's even fair to
to ask an executive you know what their
plan is beyond Charlotte and so forth so
you know they're in the positions
they're in you know at NASCAR and in
their respective you know companies
across you know across our sport that
make those decisions and you know I'm
gonna do as I'm told the way you're
gonna get behind the wheel and you're
gonna race you're gonna make some left
turns so in that regard as well when
when you said that that things are
changing for Darlington can you give me
an example about how things are changing
where you're like okay I've got this
plan but now you might have to have a
different plan literally in just the way
that you do anything protocol wise just
because of safety reasons I think that's
you know that's exactly I think they're
just trying to you know make sure that
procedurally you know travel and us
going into the racetrack and and how
people interact with each other I mean I
think all those things are still being
ironed out and you know I think they're
right at the tail end of of having it
all done you know luckily we still have
a couple weeks almost a couple weeks so
I think they've done a really good job
and getting a set plan and doing it
properly and get it distributed with
plenty of time I mean I think most every
team was well everything was prepared to
go race at Atlanta you know we were we
were all headed to the racetrack on
Friday morning when all this happened so
you know cars were in a position to
already go to the racetrack so I think
you know everybody's had plenty of time
to to prep for this and you know
I think that uh I think would be
interesting like I said I'm I'm just
looking forward to to get back to racing
now this may be a stupid question chase
which is a great way to setup a question
in my business Bali
okay I mean have you been doing any
simulating any video games anything that
just keep keep sharp in any way shape or
form
yeah Vanunu on racing yeah I've been
doing a lot of i racing you know over
the past heck month month and a half now
so yeah there's a lot of that going on
so anything is it close is it is it
there is it feel like the real thing
it's not bad honestly it's um you know
that they've done a really good job with
that it's been you know the past don't
feel like ten years or so they they've
advanced a lot and in that in that
simulator and simulation and how the
cars drive and things so yeah I don't
think it hurts you you know to mess with
its own you know I think that you know
it's obviously different in some aspects
from the real thing but you know keeping
you sharp and and and things of that
nature from a you know reflex
I guess trainer type thing is not a not
a bad thing so then how would you term
yourself
last one for you here chase by the way I
appreciate the time and again that you
know there's so much obviously real life
conversation involved in what we are all
hoping is a live sporting event that we
can enjoy feel normal and you are safe
doing it and we could keep seeing it
that it's as repeatable but you are the
one who's behind the wheel you're the
one who's got to deal with this you're
the one who's got also being a
leadership role for your for your team
for your crew how do you feel about all
this yeah you know I think it's it's
kind of one of those things that I
really don't have a good answer for you
until we until we get there and kind of
give it a go
I think there's just a lot of there's
just a lot of unknowns you know still
and and how you know how it's gonna feel
without having any people there you know
it is a sporting event and you know it
is gonna be odd to be at a sporting
event without spectators I mean that's
that's part of it always has been
so just nowadays with with the way
society is and things being you know
revolving around television and and you
know these streaming apps and things we
are you know capable to capable of
delivering our product in different ways
and at least distributed to people to
where they can see it and not have to be
sitting there and put themselves and uh
in a safety risk to watch it so I think
it's you know it's unique but it's
something that technology has provided
for us to do and like I said I'm looking
forward to looking forward to racing I
guess once you're in behind the wheel
the car and the protocols are set up for
for the rest of your team to stay safe I
guess it's just a race right when it
comes down it's just a race just with
nobody they hit there in person to watch
it's gonna be but it's don't gonna be a
UH it's gonna be a different vibe for
sure but there'll be a lot of people
sitting at home watching chase there's
no question about that you know yeah I
would have to think so I'm excited about
that part don't it okay and are you
excited about Todd Gurley coming to play
for the Falcons I mean that I think that
it's all your touch points sports watch
otherwise right yeah definitely
you know George a guy coming back to
Atlanta so I think any any fan of the
Bulldogs are gonna be excited about that
mood so I'm looking forward to seeing I
does I know he's you know you know how
to had a tough year last year or
whatever but I think he's plenty capable
of doing some good things so look
forward to watch him chase thank you for
the time be safe stay safe stay healthy
and and and have a good have a good 11
days and and I hope it goes exactly the
way you and the rest of your the rest of
the sport wants it and and we get to we
get to see this and give people a little
bit of a break yeah absolutely I
appreciate it thanks for having me you
gotta it's chase Elliott at chase
Elliott on Twitter at chase Elliott 9 on
Instagram hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here